die Regierung hat Tritt gefasst seit sie trtin
gefasst hat endgültig Tritt gefasst die grüne
Basis ist verzweifelt das gebe ich zu die
grüne Basis kann überhaupt nicht begreifen
dass die Spitze der Bewegung tatsächlich im
Arsch der Institutionen angekommen ist so
war das do nie gemeint der berühmte March durch
die Institutionen das war immer nur als schöne
polynese gedacht der Weg ist das Ziel da muss man
im Kreis laufen sonst wir nichts für viele grüne
Sympathisanten sind die ganzen Alternativen
Gesellschaftsentwürfe wie ein Leben ohne Auto
ohne Flüge in die Karibik ohne Bundeswehr das
war immer nur hirnjogging das sind Geschichten
aus Taus einer WG aber das kann man doch nicht
machen Joschka Fischer hat die Sache auf den
Punkt gebracht in einer Rede das war z Jahre vor
der Parteispendenaffäre da hat der Fischer gesagt
die etablierten Parteien das sind Steinkirchen
da kann auch der dachstümer abbrennen es sind
Stein K die bleiben immer stehen wir Grünen hat
er gesagt wir sind eine Zeltmission und das ist
das Gute Bild die Grünen sind in zeldmission
man fährt da im Sommer mal hin für ein paar
Wochen man tankt moralisch
ökologisch ethisch auf das
schöne einfache Leben auf der Isomatte die
Weltverbesserung bei billige Lambrusco im
Senfglas ver gib aber da fährt man do
wieder nach Hause zurück zum bausparf
für die geplatten Wintergarten nach 25 Jahren
Bewegung bestehen die Grünen zum größten Teil
aus verbeamteten Lehrer und die Grünen Wähler
reagieren panisch seit die grünener Macht sind
verlieren über jeder Landtagswahl oder warum die
grünne Wähler haben Angst die grünne Wähler haben
Angst dass die zentralen Forderungen der
Grünen wie Tempolimit Ökosteuer Doppelpass
Frauenquote das SAS wirklich Politik werden
könnte das will doch keiner wer will denn so
leben ja klar muss man das fordern fordern muss
man das aber das muss man da auseinander halten
können wenn ein Katholik vor ihnen steht
und ihen was vom Paradies vorschwärmt
kommen sie da auf die Idee sie können
dem einen gefallen tun wenn Sie den
erschießen die grüne Zeltmission erlebt
ihre Transformation von der Sekte zur
Kirche sektier das sind Eiferer die die
glauben wirklich jeden Quatsch den die sagen
Kirchgänger sind gelassen die sagen einmal
die Woche dass sie den Quatsch glauben geh
verkaufe alles was du hast und gib es den Armen
können Sie stundenlang anhören er geht ein Kamel
durch ein nadelöh als dass ein reicher
in den Himmel kommt hat sie das schon mal
beunruhigt dann sitz die Katholiken da
und sagen kamell der nächste Spruch die
Katholiken haben den menschchaut man muss die
moralische messelatte so hochhängen dass man n
drunter wegspringen kann liebe deine Feinde ja
super wenn es nicht klapp kann man no beichten
gehen und das wollen die grüne WLE auch
die Grünen Wähler die wollen 200 Brettern
auf der Autobahn aber hinter beichten gehen
Berz Schlauch z.B die wollen im Kosovo Krieg
führen aber sich hinter beschweren dürfen
man hätte wenigstens gesunde Munition nehmen
können
die wollen auch nach Bali Urlaub fliegen
aber mit so ein bisschen schlechten
Gewissen al das sollte man nicht tun das
ist das ist ökologisch aber es ist schön
aber die grüne Zeltmission wird sich nur dann
etablieren wenn sie ihren Wählern die Sicherheit
gibt die Grünen Forderung sie genauso ernst zu
nehmen wie wer auf die l Wange schlägt im Halter
auch die rechte hin und die Grünen machen das
68er die flexibelste Generation die je diesen
Planeten niedergetrampelt hat die sind schon
so manche Wasserwerfer ausgewichen Otto shili
der flexibelste grüne 68er aller Zeiten der ist
jetzt schon wieder 68 der ist praktisch immer 68
Otto chili ist damals vor den wasserwer Vers
schnell weggelaufen der hat von
hinten eingeholen und sitzt jetzt
drauf
und kaum hat er sein Anthroposoph und Popo Kontakt
aufgenommen meinte Chili jetzt ist das Boot aber
voll und diese Flexibilität der Grünen 68er das
ist das was Leute wie Roland Koch nicht ertragen
können Roland Koch den kennen sie ne der hat
ger Wied den rückriff von scharin geforder
hol Experte ne also ich meine den haben sie ja so
auf dem Lügen erwi der könn schon zurücklaufen ne
wenn Lügner kurze Beine hätten könnte der Koch
dem Gesi im Stehen von unten in die Nase gucken